okay thank you everyone for joining once
again this is going to be our last
session with prepared material where we
will actually talk about some of the
host-pathogen interaction project ideas
we'll talk about kind of a summary of
what we have learned throughout the
program and we'll talk a little bit more
in detail about protein-protein
interaction and host response and
different immune response factors also
how this can be applied to clinical
situations for drug discovery probe acts
in the design and other topics related
to patients so the before we do that I
do want to mention that there has been
quite a lot of activity on the platform
throughout this whole program and I
think it's very exciting for us to see
how much you have been able to
accomplish in terms of completing
different courses and being able to
translate some of the course material
and the sessions that we've had together
into project proposals so we do have a
number of different projects proposed
that we'll review towards the end I
think that we also leveraged a lot of
different elements of the program very
effectively by having a lot of
interaction throughout the different
issues that are coming up as you know
and technology can be very good and some
sometimes also cause issues that we have
to work through so I thought that it was
an overall good experience being able to
identify challenges that came up and
addressed them and hopefully most of you
have been able to resolve some of the
issues that have come up
okay yes and we will talk to the topic
of project proposals you do have some
time still so let's review the program
overall and we'll get to the projects
towards the end of the program but yes
you still have time okay so on the forum
I just want to make sure that all of you
have been to the forum to review some of
the session recordings and some of the
answers to the questions that you've
posed we also have some guidelines for
project submission we'll be adding more
information to there over the weekend so
make sure that you review that and to
kind of see where we are as a group
let's also review the program overall so
that we remember what kinds of topics
were covered in different sessions and
how they apply to the problem of finding
a project data set and developing a
project based on some of the some of the
assignments and some of the material
that we've gone through throughout this
program so as you remember we started
from talking about next-generation
sequencing
how to understand the different file
formats a line reads to the reference
genome annotate those elements that we
find and find different aspects of
pipeline output including the output
that is intended for analysis or output
that could be analyzed different ways
like non map reads that we can then take
and align to a database of viral genomes
so I hope that from that session what
you've learned is that we have many
different types of next-generation
sequencing techniques this is an
important part to remember as you start
looking at the different projects
because there's a lot of fast and fast
queue and bam and sedan files and all
kinds of variations in terms of how that
data was produced so paying attention to
exactly which instrument
and what type of information is in those
files is going to be important for you
to start applying the different analysis
techniques I thought I think that it's
also important that there's you know a
huge amount of data out there and this
data represents a big opportunity for us
to discover novel things that have not
been reported that have not been
published and I think that first project
that we asked all of you to try and go
through illustrates that kind of a
problem many different cell lines are
being used for development of biologics
which could include vaccines and
sometimes those can get contaminated
with viruses so it's important to review
how something of this material is that
is available online can point us in that
direction after that we talked about
multiple sequence alignments when we
identify a genomic sequence and we can
compare that sequence to a different
sequence or even multiple sequences
looking for variation and looking for
consensus sequences also understanding
the quality of consensus sequencing when
we find a consensus genome what does
that really represent in terms of
relationships on one hand and also in
terms of what kinds of an agreement do
we see and how much of that agreement is
reliable or non reliable then we talked
about we did some practice analysis
where we looked at different types of
comparisons between FASTA files and fast
queue files where we talked about how we
can align multiple sequences we can also
compare different consensus sequences or
we can look for variation that is
contained within fast queue files and we
looked at some of the setting up some of
the pipeline's finding the data making
sure that the data is organized in a
proper way and we know where to find
metadata about each data
said so we know where it came from and
find things like geolocation or even
consider different sizes and different
coverage that is found for different
files we then talked about comparison of
different workflow so essentially how we
can leverage some of the different
sections that we have on the platform
but also how did those translate to
publicly available types of types of
methods okay so if you could please keep
your microphones muted thank you okay so
we talked about different pipelines and
looked at the different outputs and
different results and hopefully you've
throughout this whole program you've
been able to gain experience in
analyzing different types of datasets
finding the right outputs and extracting
the most information out of those
outputs so that you can get closer to
biological interpretation after that we
started talking about how an infection
caused by a virus can develop into these
pandemic or pandemic es outbreaks how
there's there are many factors that play
into that and we can study those
different factors looking at data
collected from host species that could
be reservoirs for these pandemic
outbreaks how we can look at also
different patient populations and and
then study the virus development over
time how it acquires the capability to
spread rapidly between humans and also
how that causes disease symptoms that
are severe so we then talked about
disease progression and how the
different types of phenotypes associated
with disease
develop as a result of different types
of viruses we talked about different
started talking about different viral
proteins that acquire specific mutations
and those mutations could lead to novel
types of phenotypes and disease what we
call disease right then we talked about
how we can identify some of the factors
related to the origins of human
infection with corona viruses and looked
at the comparison between hosts
intermediate hosts and humans and then
also we could apply the same idea to
multiple types of comparisons and so I
hope that from that we saw on saw a way
to find data and present analysis
results and conclude from those analysis
results in specific ways how potential
routes of transmission and origin could
be inferred okay question I got problem
to visualize the output of my result can
I go through specific software to
resolve this problem yes definitely so
if you could again post that question on
the forum and I'd be happy to you know
post an answer there I think for this
session we have a lot of things to go
through so I'll try to if we have time
but if not please post it on the forum
okay so then we started talking about
different types of mutations variants
how we can look at different properties
of mutations and think about how those
properties affect the 3d structure of
proteins and how we can map those and
understand what impact that might have
for example on binding to cell receptors
or also in general how we can start
understanding by looking at mutation
variants what types of mutation variants
could be beneficial or detrimental for
the viral out of
that type of information is has
different types of significance and that
different types of significance could be
for vaccine design when we think of
areas that have a lot of variation does
that area on the protein for example
have an impact for her vaccine a good
example for that is the bola virus
vaccine that was designed and it was
designed around a specific change in the
glycoprotein of the Ebola virus that
seemed to have increased in fact if 'ti
so knowing that specific variation like
that is going to have an impact on the
pathogenesis of disease and also on
prevalence of that specific disease
helps understand how that disease could
be what kinds of interventions could be
designed and finally today what we'll
talk about is host-pathogen interactions
so we'll talk about how the host
interacting with sorry how the pathogen
interacting with the host really
interacts at the level of proteins we'll
talk a little bit more about how complex
those proteins encoded in the viral
genome can be by making complexes of
proteins and how those actually cause
and modulate the host response like the
immune response as well as how those can
cause specific types of reaction that
are going to be specific to different
people different patients and we'll do
that by looking at specific types of
data so up until now we dealt a lot with
genomic data we looked at how to find
mutations how to align mutation how to
align genomic sequences and we also
asked you a few sessions ago to start
looking at RNA seek how to analyze gene
expression and Aiza form expression data
and
this session is going to deal with some
of those types of datasets so I wanted
to provide you with a quick overview of
RNA seek so this information on RNA seek
is all included in transcriptomics one
two and three so we'll briefly talk
about that material to kind of connect
the dots because I also saw that a lot
of the questions and a lot of the
different pipelines that people have
been trying to run maybe ran into some
difficulties or conceptual disconnects
between the methods and why those
methods are useful and what types of
problems do they really solve so to give
you an overview of of RNA seek basically
RNA seek is separated into two parts
there's the processing part and then
there's the downstream analysis part so
let's start with the processing part
what's important when we do processing
of reads is to remember that we take
sequences of short reads those sequences
of short reads a lot of times have been
prepared using very specific techniques
and so it's important to clean up those
reads we don't take all of the reads
because they can contain a lot of junk
and they can also contain a lot of
variation that is technical in nature
it's not representative of the
biological condition that we are trying
to study
so pre-processing is an important step
especially for highly expressed genes
that we will study later that become
significant and so that's why removing
those technical variations is going to
be important the second part is mapping
there are a number of different mapping
techniques and the main idea here is
that we have genes that consist of exons
and a big part of the translation the
transcription sorry process is when a
specific gene sequence is alternatively
spliced and that alternative splicing
appears to have a major role in a number
of different conditions so when we map
on
known transcripts we are essentially
forgetting about the possibility of that
alternative splicing variation to be
present in our data the alternatives to
mapping unknown sets of transcripts
which might be a lot faster if that part
of information is not relevant but the
alternative is to really map all of the
reads on the reference genome to
identify novel transcripts and all the
variations of transcripts essentially
preparing a transcriptome and that
transcriptome could be then used as an
alignment reference instead of the
genome finally after that step we need
to quantify the level of expression
estimation of level of expression is not
a straightforward task because those
reads are not going to have a very
consistent coverage and so to say that a
transcript or a gene is expressed at a
certain number is not going to be so
trivial so the way that it is done is
using different types of fairly complex
algorithms that utilize a model that has
relevance for how different sections are
covered already and how to detect real
variation that is statistically
significant also it's important to
utilize different types of normalization
techniques but it's important also to
remember which ones were used because
sometimes when we do downstream analysis
this type of normalization will
interfere with the types of analyses
that we would like to do for example
differential expression is going to
require raw sequencing counts so read
counts instead of some normalization
like fpkm or TPM that includes
normalization for the total number of
reads and for the length of genes in
some cases okay quick question does the
pre-processing applies also for days
there that we find on databases like
NCBI or only when we do sequencing for
experiments no well NCBI can contains
data if we're talking about
fast queue files that contain read
individual reads you know that was just
deposited by the whoever produced the
experiment so whether you made the
experiment or somebody else made the
experiment they still use a specific
library they still use a PCR
amplification and so those things are
going to be important to remove and only
take reads of high quality and so those
trim automatic and PCA are removable of
duplicates are going to be important in
either case because oftentimes we don't
know exactly how those weights were
generated okay so a quick overview of a
processing pipeline we take those
pre-processing steps we utilize some
kind of mapping techniques that might
include mapping or transcripts or a
combined strategy of mapping on the
genome and then identification of novel
isoforms and then some form of
quantification there's a number of
different methods to do that finally
what do we get at the end of this
pipeline at the end of this pipeline we
can get a table of expression that looks
something like this for example here in
this output you can see genes for the
human genome ENS cheese and ensembl idea
of the human genome you see that it is
actually different transcripts of that
gene point 13 means this the transcript
of this gene and then here you can also
see in the call of names that this is
already cleaned using traumatic for
example no adapters without PCR and you
can see that this was produced using
paired end reads here you see some
numbers and these numbers are going to
be important for us to understand
just even oftentimes by looking at them
okay for example we have different
distribution of data right and a lot of
you have looked at quantile
normalization and transformation of this
table to log normal scale so those types
of transformations are going to change
the numbers that you see inside
often times you will see that these are
not full numbers so 2.9 or 50 is 1.78
and that right away tells you that there
was some level of normalization here
already
okay difference between cuffs links and
cuffs merge well if you look right here
this tells you exactly what these do so
cuff links is either form construction
so you actually construct how an isoform
or a gene transcript consists of what
different exons and cuffs merge adds
this information to the GTF file the TF
file is then used to map those reads on
transcripts okay so we have this gene
expression table and after that gene
expression table is obtained we can add
a downstream a number of downstream
types of analyses for example
differential gene expression but
differential gene expression can also
work just if you have a table of
expression so when you produce the table
of expression yourself it's important to
remember again that you use raw read
counts
instead of TPM and fpkm if you find that
table of expression somewhere else
also look for what exactly are the units
that I see here and so then once you've
got your right types of table of
expression so you have your samples and
expression of genes those genes have to
be the same across all of the samples
that you are going to compare and then
you can organize them by groups for
example in each group you can have a
minimum of three samples and then you
can compare conditions that those
samples represent obviously doing
exploratory analysis for that is going
to be important as well but here you can
find for example a workflow where you
can just add those step
at the end of the same pipeline and add
things like de seeks a differential
expression of genes how do we find those
our Sam or sorry or edge our or
comforter or some of these other
techniques and all of their outputs are
actually going to allow us to
differentiate between statistically
significant and statistically
insignificant genes that represent some
kind of a true variation between these
conditions so here you have condition
one condition two between different
samples and you only want to select
genes that represent some kind of a
difference how do we find those genes we
find those genes by looking at log fold
change so full change represents by how
much are those conditions different and
the just a p-value adjusted p-value
allows us to differentiate between
statistically noisy and clear data so we
know where is the signal and where is
the noise what is the noise noise is the
internal variation within that group so
if within a group there's a lot of high
and lows then maybe this is not truly a
condition maybe this is some random
collection of samples they don't really
represent a true change in that
condition and so those are some of the
topics that are described in
transcriptomics too as a result we can
also visualize specific genes that are
responsible for those different changes
between conditions and they also
utilized elements of clustering to help
us understand how those different genes
are organized within some kind of
comparison beyond that when we talk
about different patterns right so as you
saw here the pattern could have a lot of
variation within it we can make some
general assumptions by forcing this to
be only representative of two conditions
for example but in so many cases once we
get beyond
small numbers of samples we start seeing
a lot of variation and that variation is
going to be based on these more subtle
variations within gene and within sample
expression levels and then we can start
applying machine learning to study those
different patterns and some of the
things that we can use machine learning
is for exploratory data analysis where
we do principal component analysis and
visually see how variants in data helps
describe different samples we can use it
for clustering where we want to study
how closely related some samples are and
you can see that it is a lot like the
multiple sequence alignment and
phylogenetic tree that we did also
allows us to assign some kind of a
distance metric to similarity we can use
it to also develop a model that helps us
differentiate between different types of
samples or classify different groups and
based on that classification to select
for features or genes in our case that
help characterize the differences
between conditions that we are studying
right so essentially this whole process
could be combined also in a sort of a
pipeline where we first explore or mine
data we look for different patterns in
the data we then determine those
patterns to be associated with some
phenotype or a group right and then we
can use additional methods for
classification and feature selection to
determine how to best characterize those
groups and potentially apply the same
model to a completely new data set that
might be coming from a completely
different source but nevertheless can
contain some similar variation that
we've discovered in our data set so in
detail all of these methods are
explained
in this collection of transcriptomics
courses transcriptomics one two and
three and I want to pause here real
quick to make sure that overall the
process of RNA seek is clear to everyone
you had a chance to review some of these
methods online in those synchronous
courses I did see a lot of your
submission of the assignments and also
questions and I think we've been able to
resolve most of them but briefly if
anyone has any questions about this
process of RNA seek I'm happy to answer
some of those questions right now
you
you
you
you
okay are there any other questions
okay Parviz that looks in Greek
you
you
so it is a little focused okay
you
okay I'm not sure okay which file output
should we use for differential
expression analysis okay so we should
use the gene expression table so table
of expression once we have that table of
expression we can load the table of
expression into the differential gene
expression method like de seek and then
assign different columns or different
samples to a condition to a group
okay but does the software find
alternative splicing automatically yes
so the process of alternative splicing
bobby's and claudia if you could let me
know that answered your question
bobby's for alternative splicing okay
yes Claudia it's just read count
not if you came with TPM and Bobby's
about the alternative splicing
alternative splicing is essentially a
combination of different exons together
now when you look at expression levels
you might have a one exon that is
expressed at three another exon that is
expressed at five and another exit on
that is expressed at one so the
alternative splicing method to determine
which either forms are expressed is to
find a pattern that it would be
consistent enough with what we see in
the data to say that maybe one gene is
producing two different transcripts and
those are expressed at different levels
so and that is done automatically that
is done within that cuff links cost
merge or some of the other tools that
are on there okay let me know Bobby so
that answers your question okay
not your van gaffar I have my set of
results submitted in NCBI which kind of
files we can take from there okay so
we'll look today at different types of
submitted data so we looked already how
we can find full genomes right on the
genome those will be fast the files we
looked at SRA those would be fast queue
files typically and then we also will
look at geo gene expression omnibus
today that gives us a table of
expression okay that will be a table of
expression and sometimes we need to work
with that table of expression a little
bit before we use it for it out okay it
will
Wilfried will these platforms be still
accessible after the end of the course
yes so for the next I will have to look
exactly again when the program ends but
for the next couple of weeks at least
the platform is there for you to
continue working on your independent
project the courses are going to be
available as well if you would like to
complete them and after the end of the
program we have a number of different
options for you to continue using either
the educational or the research platform
and we can we're happy to discuss with
you what the options are
taupey I do not always see all expected
result outputs during my transcriptomics
2 & 3 exercises so taupey it would be
great if you can point out some specific
example of what you were not able to
find some of those have changed over
time and I think majority of them are
still there maybe hidden away and some
additional folders so I'd be happy to
look into that and clarify and also make
the changes to the courses in case that
is needed okay all right buggies yes I'm
happy that I recognized that all right
excellent so everybody got their
questions answered so far for that so
how do we apply gene expression to the
study of viruses and viral proteins you
saw in previous sessions how just taking
one protein and analyzing that protein
structure can help us understand
potentially what different domains that
protein has and we call them functional
domains right so those functional
domains for example specifically that we
focused on were either a site that
separates the protein into two different
parts or we even talked about doing
specific functional domains like the
receptor binding domain and we saw how
these different elements in the single
protein can have multiple different
functions after transformation overall
how do we know all of these things well
the protein function is an area of
research that could be achieved through
multiple different types of methods
essentially we can look at amino acid
sequences where we compare sequences and
maybe there's a protein that we know
another protein that we don't know and
we can find how it is similar to
different proteins we can also look at
3d structures of proteins and infer from
the 3d structure what might you do or
what proteins might it interact with and
another approach is to look at this high
throughput data for example gene
expression would be called high
throughput data or if we analyze
molecule efficacy on different cell
lines you know that would be another
example of high throughput data so when
we look at amino acid sequences we
really can look at sequence similarity
genomic context or feature-based right
for example we can look at motifs those
motifs could have some significance we
can look at global or local sequence
similarity between different amino acid
sequences and we can also look at
genomic context right itzá where are
they placed when we look at 3d structure
we can analyze 3d structure similarity
by looking at how the 3d structure can
be aligned to different other proteins
inversely or exactly the way that we
have it right it might give us some idea
about interaction with other proteins
and other 3d structures and when we talk
about a high-throughput data we can look
at protein protein interaction if we
capture protein complexes together we
know that they interact or if we look at
gene expression we look at different
conditions and how those different
conditions are comparable or how which
elements compare those different
proteins and then also do network
analysis and so those are some of the
things that we'll talk about
for example viruses are very efficient
at storing information which means that
they have very specific sequences that
they can maintain and effectively
package with denavir Eon but individual
portions of that genomic sequence could
translate to a number of different
proteins so you can see here an example
in the original SARS one genome how the
different non-coding or non structural
proteins are produced from very specific
positions on the genome and you can see
a lot of different proteins here that
are encoded overall so it is you know
these are the known proteins at least
that we do know about there are n SP 1 n
SP 3 7 8 9 10 15 the spike protein and
protein or 7a and orth 9b and then we
also have the pl pro or the NS p3m Pro
cleavage sites and the structures of n
SP 5 7 8 10 15 etc so a lot of these
proteins have different interactions
between them so for example here you can
see how proteins connect together so n
SP 7 8 1 & 8 2 T 1 and T 2 form a
specific structure right and so these
structures are used by the virus to
interact with a number of different
proteins within the cell including
interference with a number of different
processes that the cell would employ to
attack the virus because it recognizes
it
to support the replication and also
utilize and trick the cell machinery
into doing whatever the virus needs
instead of what the cell needs so here
are some examples as you remember we
kind of did an overview of how the virus
enters and unpackaged is its RNA then
produced is the viral polymerase protein
and then it starts producing these sub
genomic RNAs that encode then into
different types of proteins and then
essentially the objective is to package
another set of RNA into this viral
protein so here you can already start
seeing how these different types of
activities are done in different areas
of the cell right and one important
aspect of this is this nuclear transport
cycle and the nuclear transport cycle is
important because this cycle is where
the cell can respond right so within the
nucleus you have the DNA and the DNA is
constantly used to produce like a
reference right it's constantly used to
produce different proteins that are
important for the cell right so this
might include different proteins for
signaling there from proteins for enzyme
in somatic activity metabolic activity
etc so all of that reference code for
whatever happens in the cell is within
the nucleus so when the virus enters it
is tricking the cell to do something
else
leveraging the cell functional proteins
as well and also trying to evade this
immune response and so trying to evade
this immune response is essentially
blocking some of this material that is
coming
out from the nucleus so you can see how
some of these proteins that the virus
produces when we have portions of them
in different configurations that they
can start interfering with some of those
processes that happen and that includes
affecting some of the some of the
messaging or signaling pathways that
includes cytokines like interferon that
are affected and that also includes some
of the functional ways that the cell can
respond to the to the production of
variants inside itself so here are some
examples here's an example from a
publication that says release of severe
acute respiratory syndrome coronavirus
nuclear import block enhances host
transcription and human lung cells this
is a study related to the original SARS
and what they did here is they looked at
how or six which is a non structural
protein when that protein is produced it
antagonizes interferon signalling by
blocking specifically that nuclear
import so carry of the Ferren mediated
nuclear import processes and essentially
what they did here is they understood
how ORFs
protein can help understand so if we
look at expression of cells at different
time points we can start seeing how the
or fixed protein interacts with very
specific gene promoters and impacts the
different host transcriptional factors
so you can see here vdr see Reb 1sm ad
for p53 you probably recognize that one
and others and those are critical for
the robust antiviral
response that the cell should have so
this type of information so this is a
publication has an Associated data set
so let's take a look at this data set
real quick
so I'm going to post this for all of you
I'm sorry this privately let's go to
everyone okay so let's go and take a
look at this together okay so here you
can see that again it's important to
remember what is this generated how it
is generated and this was expression
profiling by array what did they do here
sarsi Revere Bonnie or SARS Delta or six
infections of Cali three cells time
cores right so essentially they took a
wild type they took a delta or six in
other words the whole genome of this
virus without or six and they wanted to
compare transcriptomics of to be four
cells infected with these different
mutants so if you scroll down here
you'll see that they have a lot of
samples right and they tell you that
there's MOC infection it's by our right
so you have 0 3 7 12 30 36 48 54 60 and
72 so a lot of hours and so they did 3
groups basically MOC wild-type and Delta
or 6 so by looking at time course how
this infection progresses we can start
looking at gene expression of those
cells and compare those different gene
expression patterns to understand
differences so so does it kind of makes
sense what exactly they did here did
anyone have any questions about what
they did
you
or how the data was generated
okay so thinking about RNA seek what is
a way for us to summarize what happens
here right what is some method that you
have seen or potentially know from your
past experience that can help us
summarize what is going on between these
different samples overall
okay deg or differentially expressed
genes suggested by Athanasius so
differentially expressed genes is a good
idea right we can look for
differentially expressed genes but
before we do that because differentially
expressed genes would require for us to
select some group of samples from here
right and we have a lot of different
samples we have here how many in total
99 samples so before we make it specific
okay so not your and is saying PCA okay
Claudia saying build the transcriptome
mapping to genome etc yes we need to
build a transcriptome but once we do
that we'll have thousands of genes for
each one of these 99 samples and the
question is what to do that right so not
your run will suggested principal
component analysis and I think that is a
good direction for us to go so what is
principal component analysis actually do
principal component analysis will use
all of these different samples and all
of the genes that are included in each
sample and show us variability between
these different samples okay so let's
take a look we have this is principal
component analysis the green dots are
Delta or 6 the yellow ones are mock
infected and the wild-type are the wild
type right the poo genome and so here
what you can see is that at 0 hours
right so before infection started you
can see here that all of them grouped
together this is by the way only the 0
so only 3 groups after infection so
before infection they all look the same
right and that's what the principal
component analysis shows us is that
before there's not really a lot of
variability between them they're all
mixed together but as they start getting
affected right they start spreading
apart and so at the end we can see that
a lot of these are separate right
they're in separate positions on this
principal component principal component
to which is the y-axis which is not the
most significant right so the most
significant here is principal component
one which is the difference between
non-infected
and infected which makes sense right but
after infection there's still a large
portion of genes right and we see about
10% variability that could be explained
by the differences between that or 6
being present and or sex not being
present right so then we can start
thinking about how to prepare that
differential gene expression comparison
where we have 3 groups essentially right
but we already know that the MOC is
different from both of them and we can
forget about the 0 our samples because
they don't really have a lot of
variation there and we should start
looking post infection at some point
post infection right select those
samples and then look at differentially
expressed genes and here you can see
differential gene expression analysis
between Dorf 6 and wild-type and you can
see the different hours right so this is
6 3 hours 48 hours and 72 hours so the
later hours compared between those two
and now we can find groups of genes that
are response that could be combined in a
specific pathway right and so what we
are interested to find is how different
genes are expressed over time and also
which pathways are modulated so how are
they differently expressed between these
two different genomes does this type of
analysis make sense or the logic
behind this kind of analysis make sense
or does anyone have any questions about
this
you
okay as you're thinking about your
questions I'm just going to go back to
here and show you where is the actual
data and what could be done with to the
data to analyze them so here you can see
the expression values right here you can
see it's the biggest file or actually
not the biggest one but it's got sixteen
megabytes and you can click here on HTTP
again I'll just show you also some of
the challenges because this is not
Illumina RNA seek but this is actually a
panel but let's take a look at this data
set so this data set is produced by an
array which means that specific specific
sequences are in each cell of the array
and whatever binds to that cell is
counted but and so the biggest problem
is these things right here right so you
don't see actual gene names you have to
know the translation between this code
of the panel with the actual gene symbol
and so that will require a little bit of
time if you see here all the way there's
about 33,000 and 632 genes or a lot of
genes for each sample and here you have
the sample names right so here you have
the sample names and you can see that
they are separated into Delta or 6 and
then by our and you have multiple
replicates for each our three replicates
per hour and if you scroll down there's
mark and then there's wild-type okay so
again we start with a table of
expression where we can then use this
table of expression to run principal
component analysis understand how the
sample is overall differ select specific
samples from here and run differential
gene expression and then one of the key
challenges is a challenge not related to
analysis but related to the technical
mechanism that this data was produced so
how do we actually identify what genes
are these right okay so that's a brief
overview of an example how we can use
right - what is this method allows us of
us to do it allows us to study the
protein function using high-throughput
data
okay yeah so you cannot actually use
David to do this you have to find a
specific panel that they use the
specific array so you have to find
profiling by array and somewhere here
okay so this is the platform that they
used and each one of these has a
specific naming to convert those to gene
names okay there these are going to be
probe names
you
you
so you have to use an imitation process
to convert those names okay so that's
just one technical difficulty but the
idea here right so the idea of finding a
data set that can help us understand
protein function we have gene expression
data using high-throughput sequencing we
can then compare those conditions and
identify what is the protein function
when it is present it has a certain
function when it's not present that
function is not there and if we look at
the publication in the publication this
is what they found
right so they found our data
demonstrated that 4f6 protein expression
attenuates the activity of numerous
carrier Ferren dependent host
transcription factors that are crucial
that are critical for establishing
antiviral responses and regulating key
host responses during virus infection
and they also confirm their results by
proteomic and chromatin
immunoprecipitation
assay analyses what what is proteomic
and chromatin immunoprecipitation
chromatin immunoprecipitation means that
you have antibodies that connect to
specific types of proteins so if once
they found the specific genes that are
modulated for example present or not
present
you can design an antibody that will
connect to those proteins or protein
complexes even and then take only those
proteins out and then do mass
spectrometry for example or look at
specific binding of those antibodies to
a position on the genome and analyze
which proteins those were and by that
way you can confirm through proteomics
or immuno precipitation which specific
proteins are actually produced without
dealing with you know differential gene
expression overall where you do have a
lot of noise so that's a way to confirm
those results the data strongly
for the hypothesis that viral
antagonists of nuclear import actively
manipulate host responses in specific
hierarchical patterns contributing to
the viral pathogenic potential in vivo
importantly these studies and modeling
approaches are not only provide
templates for evaluating virus
antagonism of nuclear import processes
but also can reveal candidate cellular
genes and pathways that might
significantly influence disease outcomes
following severe acute respiratory
syndrome coronavirus infection and Reba
okay so I think a very interesting study
we have that data we can find that data
we can analyze that data I hope that
this gives you some ideas on how you can
think about the project of your own what
are some similar things that could be
found based on same kind of an idea here
you have another publication severe
acute respiratory syndrome coronavirus
protein six mediates ubiquitin dependent
produce thermal degradation of n and
when they see and stat interactor so
there's the stat pathway the interferon
signalling pathway you can see that
those viral proteins again that we don't
know what their function is have been
studied again using this kind of an
analysis to understand how it interferes
with specific interferon signalling
pathway right so if the cell wants to
enable some kind of an immune response
the virus can use these
non-instructional proteins to interact
with that and here you can see the other
side of it where you have an ability to
discover how p53 which is a host protein
how it regulates salt corona virus
replication and it's targeted by the
SARS unique domain and PL probe via III
ubiquitin ligase rch y1 all right so
highly pathogenic
respiratory syndrome coronavirus has
developed strategies to inhibit host
immune recognition we identified
cellular III ubiquitin ligase ring
finger and CH why zinc finger domain
containing one as an interacting partner
of the viral SARS unique domain and the
pain like protease and as a consequence
the involvement of cellular p53 as
antagonists of corona virus replication
okay and even further they did a more
detailed analysis here okay so a good
question where to get the data for the
paper okay so for example if you have a
paper let's see at this one NCBI that's
why it's a good place to look for things
will actually help you find some of
these datasets okay so you can see this
data this paper
and within this paper it depends again
what exactly did they do here right so
you do have to look into you know what
exactly they did not all the paper and
not all the papers are going to utilize
this next generation sequencing
necessarily right bees for example what
they did here is they did some analysis
of cell culture and expression by GFP
right so a different way to interpret
and what is being expressed but if you
do want to find a dataset on something
like this I'll give you some examples
here in a second
oftentimes if you once you determine
what your interest is right and that's
what we want to focus on today it is you
know how do you go from having an idea
right having some biological
understanding of the different processes
involved and look for data that can help
you make that analysis your own so let
me walk through some of these slides and
then we'll talk about you know actually
finding some data that you can base your
analysis on okay so we talked about a
couple of these other examples
okay let me pause here so bobby's is
saying if we found a good set of
transcriptomics data so gene expression
of cell lines we want to use but they're
not raw data we can only find processed
data is there any way to incorporate
them in our analysis or we just need to
find a different set of data what would
you recommend to do so yes sometimes you
will not have raw data available only
gene expression tables if those gene
expression tables are in a specific
format in front most likely you can use
them and that is fine the reason why we
say it's good to find the raw data is
because on one side when you present
your analysis result it's good to show
how
analysis from the very beginning all the
way until the very end and that is more
for you if you want to just understand a
biological process then you probably
want to just make sure that the data
that you take right so for example in
this previous example when we have this
array data you know I don't know what
this data is in right so this data is
from an array but I will have to dig in
to find out exactly what is this
quantification method that is being used
to produce these numbers and that might
have some impact on the types of
analyses that I would like to do and
that's the reason why it's easier
sometimes to find the raw data okay from
grace can we plan the project with
preprints yes yes definitely preprints
give you a framework on how to think
about the data set but also provide you
with all the metadata how did they
generate the data you know what did they
what is the experiment design that they
had you know who processed the data etc
so that that's the information that you
need to guide your analysis and so you
can definitely start from the preprint
okay
talked about different proteins right
how to characterize those proteins using
high-throughput sequencing what types of
ideas we can get out of them to
understand how the different proteins of
the pathogen interact with the proteins
of the cell typically we do look at
specific viruses or similar conditions
but sometimes there's a good example we
can study different features associated
with disease for example we know in
corona viruses that h2 expression is
important and cytokine pathways are also
important
sometimes those could be studied from
similar conditions right so here you
have an example we present evidence that
viral respiratory infections are
potential mechanisms of h2
overexpression in patients with asthma
okay so this is a study that is not
focused on how right so up until now we
were asking the question how does the
virus cause infection or how does the
virus for example interact with the host
proteins here's a different question the
question is could there be a factor with
patients potentially even caused by
other viruses okay here we're talking
about rota viruses that are in they
don't cause severe condition but this is
more a study of interaction between
various viruses right what if over
expression of h2 and susceptibility to
Co mid-nineteen infection is actually a
result of other respiratory infections
and other respiratory infections that
can cause a stew over expression and
modulate in some may be minor way the
cytokine pathways the interferon
pathways could they actually cause risk
higher levels of risk so here you can
see that the pair design experiments
across discovery and validation cohorts
of an of in asthmatic patients the
biological replicates treated with
I wrote a virus strain a and C were
compared to non treated and so here
again you have PCA of this data you have
control group and then r VN r v c and so
what might you be looking after you see
this separation right what might you be
looking in the actual gene expression
data to find who can um kind of suggest
you know what next what what what
pathways would be wouldn't we be looking
for what genes would we've been looking
for okay let's take a look at this
together
again this is available here you can see
as SRA so we can download okay 90 run
and suggesting housekeeping gene not
sure that housekeeping gene is what I
would be looking for but here you can
see this is by Illumina right and you
have the different sample so you can
actually start from the very beginning
or you can start with the actual process
data already and you can see that this
is our SEM discovery validation get
produced by yourself so this data set is
probably going to be useful for us to
you know ask
yes housekeeping gene what is the
housekeeping housekeeping gene is a gene
that we know what its expression should
be so if they report here h2 it's
overexpression you should probably look
for AES too right if they report a
cytokine surge and you know tissue
damage so we can look for pathways
related to cytokines again the Jack to
you know start one interferon pathways
that are probably going to be impacted
right between the different virus virus
is being present our VA and our VC okay
here's another example this is a
publication in cell imbalance House
response to SAR Co V two drives
development of coded 19 what's
interesting about this data let's take a
look at this data together so here's a
data so that a rich dataset that you can
find a lot of different types of data to
analyze and play around with 110
different SRA experiments
again if you read here what did they do
here we offer an in-depth analysis of
the host response to star CoV - as it
compares to other respiratory infections
right so we saw SARS one and the host
response then we saw some risk factors
may be associated with other viruses and
infecting specific types of patients but
what if we start comparing different
viruses and see how they cause different
types of immune responses for example
what they did here is treat different
types of lung cells so you can see lung
epithelium you can see different
treatments long alveolar and even they
made these cells Express human age - and
even test that here a specific drug so
if you actually look at SRA experiments
let's look at the SRA experiments and
I'll show you some interesting and by
the way this data set we prepared some
[Music]
description table let's take a look at
that
you
you
okay well this is just for the essa
railings right we will have a full data
set that you can use and you can
actually find it right here right so if
we send this to file and do run info
create file
we'll get all of the sample okay and
here you can see exactly what types of
datasets are available in terms of the
SS array right so there's a lot of links
here there should be much more okay yeah
so 330 329 sra files obviously you would
like to select some files before you
work with all of these there you go you
can go to send results to run selector
to see some of the metadata about what
kinds of you know what kinds of samples
do we actually have here okay so let's
change this to see it's me okay so here
you have more information you have here
treatment tissue and cell type and also
time after treatment so here you can see
mark treatment is oh these are different
types of viruses treated with interferon
beta super coz infected mark treatment
you
rs reinfected
okay so a lot of different types of
viruses and conditions being affected
here and also you can see what types of
tissue is available as well as here
these are not just human but also sets
then you can see here by their species
so ferrets different ages of ferrets
different types of cells okay expressing
a stew and etc
okay let me answer some of these
questions could they be looking for gene
expression or apoptotic pathway in the
previous study well yes p53 is involved
in apoptosis so you know apoptosis and
these different genes and involved in
those pathways could have could explain
what actually happens right and by the
way is this what I was looking for
ruxolitinib is a drug that is being
tested for coke at 19 right so here I
think the point is is that a rich data
set that you can start selecting
specific datasets from to really build
the comprehensive analysis of how the
host cells might be responding to covert
19:00 infection and how that infection
might be different from other viruses as
well as trying to understand how
potential treatments might have an
impact and how different even host
factors can play a role like h2
expression that is being induced claudia
is asking how are we going to create a
single file of the samples we are
interested in within a bio project to
use as input to run pipelines excellent
question okay so here you can see that
we have you know a huge variety of
different data sets of different files
right and you have specific codes for
each one right so this is like the idea
of that of that cell or the example in
this file where you have the links to
the SRA you have the same ID
right so from here you select the ones
that you're interested in for example
just the ones that were treated versus
not treated and here you select those
and create an SRA run info to upload to
the pipeline and I'll shoot your video
and actually how to practically do that
okay raw data coming from microarrays
and next-generation sequencing can be
generally treated in the same way in our
analysis yes that is correct
overall they both show expression of
genes RNA seek can give you more idea
about high visible forms and novel
isoforms it also has a better more
reliable level of expression because the
microarray can be biased based on what
exactly is the sequence it used in that
microarray and how many variations of
that same sequence could be there and
also the method of detection is not as
reliable as for our tasting all right so
these are some examples you can read
more about this publication and we also
include that in the Dropbox folder for
publications for this session so you'll
be able to find the PDF and there as
well
finally we do have an example that is
non coded related here you can see for
example similar strategy employed by
Ebola virus evasion of interferon
response by Ebola and Marburg viruses so
both of those are very they cause death
but in bola is much more pandemic it
spreads much more but here you can read
a publication on how a specific protein
so proteins VP 35 and B 24 block host
interferon alpha and beta production and
inhibit signaling downstream of the
interferon alpha and beta in the F and
gamma receptors respectively
and also VP 35 which is a component of
the viral nuclear capsid complex and
plays an essential role in viral RNA
synthesis acts as a pseudo substrate for
the cellular kinase as ikk epsilon and t
BK t1 which phosphorylate and activate
interferon regulatory factor 3 and
interferon regulatory factor 7 so you
can see how a variety of different viral
proteins that the virus can use as
structural proteins and in non
structural proteins can interact with
the different pathways and so you can
see how the differences here between
Ebola virus and Marburg virus you can
see here the Marburg virus VP 24 protein
does not detective Lee blocks that one
nuclear import and unlike Ebola virus
Marburg virus infection inhibits that
one stat 2 phosphorylation right so they
can have different ways to interact with
the human response to viral infection
and those types of differences are going
to be employed and this is you know the
same family of viruses so we expect them
to function in a similar way but
nevertheless they do not and yes here
you can have you have even a list for
those of you that are interested with
Ebola viruses that we did discuss in the
context of the program a good collection
of datasets that you can find on the
host response to Ebola virus so it's
just sorry pasted that to someone
private so here's a link therapeutics of
Ebola hemorrhagic fever whole genome
transcriptional analysis of successful
disease mitigation so this is for
treatment conserved transcriptional
response to intranasal Ebola virus
exposure in non-human primates before
onset of fever the Ebola virus species
associated with differential
pathogenicity induced distinct host
responses in human macrophages the
script
profiling of the immune response to
Ebola infection and comparison of
transcriptomic platform for analysis of
whole blood from Ebola infected say
nominal this macaques so I think
addresses a lot of the different
questions that we discussed here okay so
to summarize high-throughput profiling
of of protein function and host response
is making a lot of advances for
high-throughput screening of different
compounds repurposing of different drugs
and really understanding how these
proteins and how these viruses cause
infection um here are two reviews one is
a description of network based drug
repurposing how you can take specific so
specific drugs that have you know drugs
target specific proteins those proteins
should be important to the way that the
virus causes different responses at the
host level and so what you would want to
do is connect the host transcriptome
that is related to infection and the
drug induced transcriptome right and
there is some overlap between them where
you can start understanding if a drug
the whole idea of drug repurposing is
from you know the idea that you already
have drugs on the market that have
certain effects on the host
transcriptome right and if the same
transcriptome is being affected by the
virus could we try and repurpose this
existing drug and see whether it can fix
some of those changes and make the
infection not as severe helping the
immune system and potentially overcome
this infection so some of this I some of
these ideas are also described in this
review article
how to discover antiviral drugs so
choose viral or human protein targets
molecular dynamic simulations virtual
high throughput screening docking of
different compounds ranking them and
then also this part of it right is
related to this right here experimental
testing of top brain compounds and
really understanding at the molecular
level how do those drugs actually work
and whether they affect the same
pathways and the pathways contain
multiple targets not all of these
targets are direct targets by specific
antiviral chemicals or compounds they
could be affecting them indirectly just
like we saw what the virus does with its
proteins it actually effects indirectly
some of those signaling pathways causing
specific invasion of the immune response
so great articles also included in the
in the folder for today and hopefully
would be useful for you to think also
about some clinical applications of some
of these mechanistic studies that we've
described up until now monistic in the
sense that they describe some mechanism
and not always necessarily have a direct
clinical application okay so are there
any questions about some of these
examples and examples of how protein
function and host response could be
studied the servers allow us to create
those expression graphs well yes so you
have network analysis different
different shades of colors yes so you
probably are you talking about these
kinds of graphs yes yes so you can you
can do this okay so let me address some
of those questions
here you have utilities
and
you have heat maps right here so that's
called the heat map you need to have a
table of expression don't use all of
your 33,000 genes you're not gonna see
anything right so instead what you can
see here is I don't know 50 genes maybe
the 50 table differentially expressed
genes and across samples and also this
heat map button is going to generate an
R script if you want to modify how it
looks it's very easy to do inside the
heat map script okay how can we use geo
for pipelines so just like I showed geo
for pipelines you download the Geo
so you download that data right so just
like we saw down here this was just
downloaded directly from jr. so this is
already a table of expression once you
convert this to actual gene names or if
the Geo file was generated by an
Illumina experiment you will already
have ensembl IDs or potentially even
gene common names so that's how you can
use that directly and instead of going
through the arnie seek section alright
so instead of going through here you
have all the message for data mining
differential expression and factor
analysis and also have in here different
things like normalization principle
component analysis and all kinds of
other things to visualize your data sets
okay any other questions
yes geo is already a gene expression
table so it's not raw reads this is a
table that you can do downstream
analysis with okay so let me quickly do
a review of independent projects
nucleotide mutation correlation could
help us identify pathways between
proteins well so some mutations are
going to result in change of expression
because you know they're going to be
stop codons for example other mutations
will cause a different maybe protein to
be produced so it depends on what you
mean exactly nucleotide mutation
correlation if you have mutation data
and gene expression data you can find
correlation between mutations and gene
expression and that will potentially
have an impact on different pathways now
protein-protein interaction pathways are
different than signaling pathways so
there's multiple different pathways here
that we can talk about so I think your
question maybe requires more attention
um okay let's get to yes we do have to
finish here in just a couple of minutes
and let's try to quickly summarize where
we're going with the difference projects
okay so independent projects your target
for submitting an independent project
again this is not very strict right
we're not in college here you're doing
an online course so it's really up to
you you don't have to do an independent
project if you don't want to independent
project is really a goal for you if you
have that you can submit it and get
assistance from us to get it farther or
maybe and answer any technical questions
that you might have in the context of
this program right well once the program
is over what you will not have access to
is our tools and our support but you
will still be able to do your own
analysis if you wish to so just quickly
we have we will give you some datasets
and examples we already have but we will
provide you with more guided tutorials
on how to utilize some of these methods
in the context of different viruses
including the corona virus including
these different types of infectious
diseases like tuberculosis not a virus
but nevertheless and
such disease we have the datasets and
explanation of methods for the oats the
deep sequencing that we discussed last
time some defective viral genomes
involvement in the enterovirus d68 a
recurring pandemic in kids so important
to find ways that this virus is causing
that pandemic Ebola and here again you
have multiple types of ideas or multiple
types of analyses that you can do so
before jumping to a specific project I
think having a sense of you know the
different types of analyses that could
be done that we've done in the context
of this program can potentially give you
insights into what you can do and how
you can reanalyze the same data or take
data from multiple sources combine it
with different methods that are
described in different publications that
you've seen and ultimately creating a
novel project that is your own right so
that is the objective of the project so
thinking about that project has to do
with some iterative review of available
data and of review of publications right
so once you do that I think it's
important to start planning your
analysis to understand potentially how
long it might take for you to complete
it right so when you're thinking of a
project and you want to complete the
project by the time that the program is
over plan your analysis in such a way
that you have enough time to complete it
right there's a lot of steps here each
step might take a different time and
thinking about that time is important
for you to get there by the end of the
program we do have a number of people
that have already submitted projects and
potentially next week we will announce
the different project ideas once we have
the time to review them and have those
projects listed out on the forum so if
you don't
to work on a project of your own or
you're a little bit overwhelmed with the
different possibilities and you would
like to work with a team of other
participants from this program and
together develop a project that is more
impactful I think that's an excellent
way to go
so we'll post some projects where you'll
be able to say I want to join that team
instead of working independently that
will require for you to start
interacting with those other members so
remember how from the beginning of the
program we asked all of you to have a
completed profile yes let me remind you
how to submit the project so again we
have the forum on the forum there's a
link to a forum that you might have to
fill out that forum has multiple fields
I've shown before right so you go to the
forum those fields have to be filled out
it includes the problem statement the
project description okay so if you go
right here
project submission and discussion
and by the way if you want to post that
you would like to work with somebody
else you can also post that here
okay so here project submission page you
click right here and this is as a member
of this program you should have access
to this page well you'll see the form
and be able to submit that form to us
and we even reviewed that form and we
answer any questions and we make sure
that the project is feasible and has you
know the data that is required to
conduct that kind of analysis etc and
ultimately you'll be able to start
working on that project so remember how
we told you that it's very important to
have a completed profile again that
profile gives you a sense of what the
background of the person is and how
advanced are they and what kinds of
materials have they already completed
and what they know and or don't know yet
how to do you know we obviously have
some other examples of standing of
people that have profiles that stand out
and so we we expect that you know most
of you will be at around 5,000 points
that's kind of the baseline those of you
that have done more are already past
10,000 points we have a number of people
like those but after completing your
project so this is a good example if
somebody has completed a project from
beginning to the end you can see that
she has over 43,000 points so really you
gain a lot of experience particularly
during that time when you work on a
project of your own now some of you here
might be interested in doing more than a
student project right you might actually
want to get involved in research
projects and so I do want to mention
that we have an opportunity for you if
you are making significant advances with
your project you're interested and
motivated and have the time we have a
research internship that is on a rolling
basis you can actually get into that
research internship or a research
fellowship contribute to some projects
that are ongoing and even get involved
in projects that will be
published at some time or presented at
posters at different conferences
potentially if you're interested you
want to become a mentor we have some
other programs that are ongoing and you
can get involved in this program to
eventually become a mentor there as well
so just link there from mohit also on
the research internship if you're
interested in continuing to learn about
novel coronavirus and the different
aspects of processing different types of
next-generation sequencing data and
working with protein data and doing more
in that domain we have a program that is
starting soon so you're you're welcome
to join that program as well if you're
seeing how this yes all of these are
online so you can do them remotely they
require different types of commitments
but they are all online if you're
interested in seeing how this applies
not only to viruses but also to oncology
including on Kalitta crisis and
precision medicine where individual
factors play a role so we do have a
program on precision medicine as well
it's a short some of these are fairly
short programs and not as intensive as
this one some of them are more involved
so again if you want to have more
information about some of these programs
please reach out to us this is the last
session that we did in the context of
this program for infectious diseases I
hope that you enjoyed the program so far
and hopefully you will be able to
participate in the project and will
continue to interact with you and we
will propose individual times to meet
with either you individually or a group
of you that are working on the same
project to discuss different project
ideas and discuss different strategies
to help you make it more effective
so I really enjoyed this time
interacting with all of you up until now
and will continue and look forward to
interact with you and thank you Serena
and all of you that have joined okay
questions for submission of project
previous dataset is necessary
[Music]
so previous data sets obviously you need
a data set so I don't know what you
inviting the word previous but you do
need the data set to work with yes
all right great and thank you all for
all the feedback
how do estimate the timeline for this
project well a lot of it will depend on
how many datasets how many steps to get
that program to a biological interpreter
or result so once you submit your
proposal we actually take a lot of time
to review your proposal and provide you
with some feedback and talk to you about
planning your analysis effectively so if
you can submit it as soon as possible
we'll be starting to review these
projects and providing feedback and then
scheduling and time to interact with
either you independently or if you have
team working with you then to interact
with the whole team and start thinking
together how we can execute this in the
best and the shortest time frame
possible
approximately when will we have the
feedback you know we're starting to do
it now I already started looking at some
of them after these sessions are
complete and we have a lot more time to
start focusing on the project ideas so
you know hopefully as soon as Monday
you'll start getting those feedback
those feedbacks
all right excellent well thank you very
much again for joining and for everybody
else that contributed to this and we
will look forward to interacting with
you again soon
you
you